[Music]
[Music]
it's a pleasure to welcome everyone to
MIT on this frighten glorious morning
I'm Bob Brown the Provost of MIT and I'm
standing in for president Charles vest
who happens to be travelling he Chuck
would very much loved to be here doing
his time as president this will be the
only Nobel laureate that we've received
that he does not introduce personally
it's a glorious day for American science
for MIT and for the Department of
Physics with the awarding of the Nobel
Prize in Physics to Professor Frank will
check I'm gonna let mark Kastner the
department head in physics make the
formal introduction mark thanks Bob
before I begin I'd like to introduce two
other physics Nobel laureates who are
here Jerry Friedman and Wolfgang
ketterle
[Applause]
Jerri
shared the prize with the late Henry
Kendall another faculty member in our
department in 1990 and when I introduced
Wolfgang to the department colloquium
after his Nobel Prize was announced in
2000 I went it out that we had had five
Nobel Prize winners in the physics
department in 25 years and I thought
that once every five years was pretty
good but the faculty should really work
a little harder and here you see they
come through Frank will Jack is as Bob
Jaffe says is a luminary he is one of
the great minds of modern physics in
1972 when Frank began his his research
on quantum chromodynamics the theory of
the strong interactions we knew there
were quarks and we knew it because of
the experiments of Jerry Friedman and
Henry Kendall and a lot was known but
the pieces of what held these quarks
together the strong interaction were
were fragmented there was no way of
putting it together the work that Frank
did with David gross and Pulitzer put
things together in a way which allowed
physics to move forward and it is one of
the great cornerstones of our
understanding of modern physics Frank
came here from frit Princeton about the
time of the Millennium and it really
began a new century for MIT physics it
gives me great pleasure to introduce him
to you
that's enough okay
an occasion like this I think is first
of all an occasion to give thanks and I
have a lot of people I want to thank I
want to thank my parents who were
first-generation Americans that my
grandparents emigrated under difficult
circumstances in world world around the
time of World War one and my parents
grew up in very difficult circumstances
in the depression but worked very hard
to get themselves educated and then to
support my education and I was very
pleased to be able to call them this
morning I also want to thank the United
States for supplying the system of
education which did so well by me I'm a
public school guy all the way and took a
beneficiary of the excellent public
schools of New York City in the 1950s
and I think it's very important that the
country continue or we cover at the
excellence in its education that it that
it's had I also got excellent
instruction at Chicago before coming to
Princeton where after that it gets
famous
I also want to thank my wife Betsy
it was the time I was meeting and
courting Betsy that I did this work and
I don't think that's entirely
coincidence and we're we're still
together and she's here and I thank her
very much although they didn't have much
to do with this work I'd also like to
thank my daughter's for making life a
lot of fun and enabling me to keep happy
and productive I think at a reasonable
level ever since
more seriously I'd like to thank the
community of physicists I guess
represented by Jerry Friedman here
especially the community of physicists
who really laid the foundation of
insight and facts that we were able to
leverage into a fundamental theory of
the strong interaction and our input
definitely was important I don't want to
be too modest about this but it would
absolutely was not from out of thin air
it was based in rooted in hard
experimental work and theoretical
insight from a large number of
communities we stood on the shoulders of
giants but also on the shoulders of a
lot of only reasonably tall people a
very large number of average height
people and and even a few Dwarfs were
important finally I'd like to thank
nature for being so kind as to really
become simple and understandable at
short distances our our work is really a
vindication of the whole idea that it is
possible to understand nature precisely
and mathematically by studying it at the
very at the funding the fundamentals
that go on at short distances so high
energies and building up from there
so I'd like to thank NIT mother nature
for her good taste in choice of
principles and symmetries and
rationality okay so I I don't know what
I'm supposed to do now so maybe I'll
just say a few words about what's up on
the board which is representative and
then then take questions
okay so this this was the result of the
calculation that came from calculating
processes in space and time where gluons
interact with other gluons and modified
the distribution of colored charge or
they can also go through intermediate
quarks and there are a number of
different kinds of processes I won't go
through the details nor give you a quiz
on this but the result of this
calculation was a formula for how the
coupling of the strong interaction
changes as a function of energy and what
we found is that as a result of quantum
fluctuations and rearrangements of color
fields in in the vacuum in empty space
what would you call the vacuum in empty
space the effective The effect of a
charge at higher and higher energies or
equivalently at shorter and shorter
distances gets weaker and weaker
this is what's called asymptotic freedom
and because the charge gets weaker in
its effect gets weaker and weaker the
particles behave more and more as if
they were free of any interactions as
the energies get larger and larger or
the N or the distances gets smaller and
smaller that's why it's called freedom
that it's also simplicity because it
means that the complications due to the
interactions become less and less severe
as or less and less necessary to take
into account as you go into higher
energies or shorter distances so that
was the formula from pen-and-paper
calculations and the original
calculations because they had many cross
checks and they involved techniques that
were pioneering at the time really
filled notebooks nowadays that
calculation is often assigned as an
exercise in quantum field theory classes
it's still difficult to do in less than
a page or two but wow that was that was
the core calculation from that
calculation it was a relatively
straightforward but not trivial exercise
to derive experimental consequences in a
variety of different experiments which
I'll be happy to explain if someone asks
one can check whether this predicted
behavior of the effective charge getting
weaker and weaker at high energies and
short distances in fact occurs and most
gratifyingly
well this is of course entirely
manufactured data but gives the spirit
of the actual occur which I didn't bring
in our prediction for how the strength
of the coupling should vary as a
function of energy has been vindicated
now by many thousands of measurements
and literally hundreds of different
kinds of experiments and so these it's I
still find it a miracle to think that
the calculations and concepts that on
the one hand you scribble on paper
match the results that are measured at
accelerators with these gigantic seem to
come from an entirely different universe
of discourse and concepts and yet one
maps onto the other with this amazing
accuracy and then I'll display one more
thing so this all has to do with the
behavior of the so called strong
interaction which is responsible for
building up protons and neutrons out of
quarks and for the interactions of
protons and neutrons that are
responsible for building up atomic
nuclei and holding them together and
responsible for our mass so if you think
you're overweight you have me to blame
the on this one is one of the
theoretical uses of this insight we
would like to construct as much as
possible a unified description of the
different forces of nature but when we
go out and measure we find that the
several of the different forces don't
seem to want to be unified and they and
that they appear to have very different
strengths so here alpha 3 is the inverse
strong coupling constant so it's alpha s
that's the same as alpha 3 there's a
coupling constant that describes the
strength of the strong interaction here
its inverse so it increases as the
energy increases and instead of getting
a curve because I've plotted with a
logarithm it gives more or less a
straight line that but the details don't
matter the point is that the coupling
constant changes as a function of the
energy and likewise the coupling
constant for the weak interactions and
for the electromagnetic interactions
change depending on the energy or
distance at which you measure them and
likewise even the gravitational
interaction and so you can see if the
dream of unification at short distances
can really be achieved by extrapolating
by extending and extrapolating this
of calculation to other interactions and
to higher energies and miracle of
miracles it works well with more or less
it works quantitatively in detail doing
justice to the accuracy of the
experiments I should say before getting
carried away that what's actually
measured is sort of what's in this oval
here and the rest is extrapolation and
those of you who know about logarithms
will know that to get a logarithm to
change by a factor of 10 is a very
enormous extrapolation so that's the
sort of thing we're talking about here
or going from a hundred GeV and energy
to ten to the eighteenth GeV and energy
to make this extrapolation so far beyond
what we've measured but because of the
success of the theater we have some
confidence that it makes sense to do and
when you do it in full detail you find
that it more or less works with the
particles we know and are however if you
really wanted to get it to work
accurately you have to up the ante
include and include something that's
called low energy supersymmetry now low
energy supersymmetry is something that
has consequences it's something that has
to show up at the next great accelerator
the Large Hadron Collider at CERN so
we're actually making predictions for
the near future we can be shot down or
not I'm not going to give back my Nobel
Prize but
if it doesn't work on the other hand
I'll be in the market for a second one
this is this is an example of how we
build on insights from the past to think
that makes predictions for the future
and it's a it's a very exciting future
indeed for this kind of work so with
that I'll take questions let me take
this opportunity to introduce one more
of our departments Nobel Prize winners
Sam ting Sam was actually our first
physics Nobel Prize at MIT and in 1976
and all the ones before this year were
in experimental physics so this is a
breakthrough year for us this is our
first prize in theoretical physics glad
to take questions
people on the phone do you have any
questions your collaboration with your
two colleagues where it took place and
the circum yeah well my collaboration
was with David gross only David gross
was an assistant professor when we began
the work he got associated got promoted
to associate professor somewhere in
there and he was my thesis adviser and
we worked very intensely together
David Politzer was a graduate student at
Harvard and we learned of his work
really only after both of both groups
had found their main results we learned
of his work through Sidney Coleman who
was was an a brilliant physicist David
polishers thesis advisor David was that
David Politzer was at Harvard and Sidney
was on leave from Harvard Princeton and
Sidney realized that we were working on
related things so we knew of each
other's existence at an early stage and
remained in friendly competition by by
having occasional communications
makes me very happy it also makes me
relieved I mean I'd be lying if I said
it came as a shock I mean we the the
theory I've thought for a long time was
very very important the data in favor of
it has been clear for at least 20 years
and so every year this time for the past
20 years or so I've had an unpleasant
week and a sleepless night I'm very
pleased that that's all over
[Music]
but also more seriously I think it's
very welcome recognition for an endeavor
understanding the fundamental
interactions of nature and understanding
them in a precise mathematical way that
is one of the crowning glories of our
culture it's one of the things that
people will think about a thousand years
from now if there are still people or or
they're robotic descendants or whatever
but it's a permanent part of the it's
one of the the real gems of our culture
that you can understand nature in this
way and then when you do you find very
beautiful things and well I hope to pay
back in the sense of using this
recognition to feed some of it back into
the field as a whole and make sure that
keeps supported and keeps vigorous
describe the theory of the strong
interaction because you kept referencing
back okay so so what is the strong
interaction when people in the 1930s
started to get a reasonably mature
understanding of what atomic nuclei were
they realized that atomic nuclei were
can be thought of as built up out of
protons and neutrons but that the
interaction that held them together
between protons and neutrons had to be a
fundamentally new interaction the
interactions that were known at the time
electromagnetism and gravity were not
sufficient to hold the Tomic nuclei
together so this became the problem of
the strong interaction what is it that
holds atomic nuclei together people in
that's not an easy thing to investigate
because nuclei are very very small
and so the experiments were at first
relatively crude they consisted it
didn't throwing different particles
together at high energies and seeing
what came out and people hoped I suppose
that what came out would be simple
building blocks and that you would
understand the protons and neutrons or
maybe the protons and neutrons
themselves which would be deflected by
ways and that would tell you what their
interactions were but what happened
instead was that when the particles were
smacked together
you found whole new worlds of phenomena
that there were many many unstable
particles besides protons and neutrons
like they have funny names like pi
maisons ro maisons lambda signaling a
lot of them are just Greek letters
anyway there so they had very in a wave
those similar properties to protons and
neutrons they had very powerful
interactions you could you could turn
protons into lambda particles but then
you could also turn lambda particles
into protons so they seemed to be more
or less on the same footing and the
understanding that whole complex of
phenomena became what's called the
problem of the strong interaction and it
got completely out of hand by the 1960s
there were hundreds of particles no real
rhyme or reason to why there were so
many or the patterns then primarily
Murray gell-mann but with a lot of help
from others started to see patterns in
this and found that he could understand
the observed kinds of particles by
postulating that they were made out of
other things quarks that had somewhat
simpler properties so some things are
made out of three quarks and other
things are made out of a quark and an
antiquark
or those are baryons and mesons and
those were the strongly interacting
particles but there was no I mean and
there was no real understanding of what
a quark was other than it was some kind
of mysterious thing that you could build
other things out of you know part of the
mystery was that individual quarks were
never discovered they don't seem to they
can't exist in isolation and so this
this was kind of a clearly provisional
understanding then well skipping a lot
of very interesting complications and in
severe deep insights certainly one of
the next great milestones was when
friedman kendall and taylor and other
their collaborators did the very smart
thing of using a microscope to study
inside of protons and neutrons of course
this is not the kind of microscope you
buy at a hardware store
it's it's a microscope that involves
very very high-energy electrons and a
lot of interpretation of of what you see
but using that they were able to probe
inside the proton and show that with
some clever interpretation what you were
seeing was something like quarks and
furthermore that the quarks inside the
proton at very short distances we're
interacting with each other surprisingly
weakly when they got close together so
that sort of posed the problem for us
how how can you get a consistent
description of entities that is
consistent with the basic principles of
quantum mechanics and special relativity
that interact very weakly at short
distances but powerfully at long
distances because we know quarks can't
separate from each other and that at
first seemed to be a contradiction
because in most consistent realizations
of quantum mechanics and special
relativity charge tends to build up had
long distances
I'm sorry start charge tends to get
shielded at long distances so the effect
coupling gets smaller at long distances
which is the opposite of what we wanted
however I mean that's the ordinary
description ordinary behavior of matter
in in dielectrics or things you learn
about in ordinary undergraduate physics
but what we found somewhat to our
amazement I think it's more to David's
amazement than to mine because I didn't
didn't know as much the we found a
unique kind of theory the so called non
abelian gauge theory a theory with very
remarkable mathematical properties and
high amounts of symmetry that had the
opposite property that instead of
charges kind of cancelling themselves
and shielding at large distances they
anti Shi anti screamed so the charge
would grow at long distances gets
smaller at small distances so a very
small seed charge could make and weak
interaction could build up to a strong
interaction and those theories were so
rare
theories that had that kind of behavior
were so rare that with only a few broad
hints from experiment and implementing
that requirement we were led to a unique
theory of what the strong interaction
had to be and that's what's now called
qcdr quantum chromodynamics so part of
that was introducing in addition to the
quarks what are called gluons colored
gluons with specific properties so along
the way we discovered gluons and showed
that the interactions really simplified
at short distances